foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage of the
studios it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
host Coleman show is my co-host today as
we answer your questions about your
careers in work and money and Ken's show
is all about your work and your career
and we'll both jump in on whatever you
want to talk about the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Green Bay Wisconsin
Craig starts this hour hi Craig how are
you
doing great how are you better than I
deserve what's up
uh just quick question uh bottom line up
front am I being a stick in the mud and
not wanting to spend money so some
details uh 38 married with six kids uh
two hundred thousand dollar household
income our house is worth probably 900
we owe 475 and have no debt outside of
the mortgage my wife has a 2015 band
with about 15 or with about 90 000 miles
on it and it's worth about 15. if we
were to sell it or trade it in
um I'm fortunate that I have a company
provided truck uh so I have no no
vehicle expense there we're in the
process of selling a paid off rental
where we're going to be
keeping about a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars
I want to take all of that and throw
that all off at our mortgage and my wife
wants to upgrade
her van to maybe a 45 or 50 000 Suburban
and and use you know 30 to 30 or 40 000
of our uh
rental you know our our income coming
back on on this on the rental house and
I guess I'm I'm struggling with the
whole reverse engineering because I
wouldn't
take off or I wouldn't take a loan more
on the mortgage to
pay the you know to to go toward a car
but I guess I'm am I am I stick in the
mud for thinking what I'm thinking I
don't think stick in the mud is the
right analogy although she may have
called you that
me being critical of myself
thus the phone call
oh well no I think you're just uh you
know you are the nerd you are like I am
at my house you're the numbers cruncher
and uh and you also happen to be the
saver and she's more of the free spirit
and more of the spender and neither one
are right or wrong uh you just and you
need each other Larry Burkett used to
say of two people just to like get
married one of you is unnecessary so
um you need opposites generally attract
and that's a good thing so we balance
each other out my wife is the natural
saver at our house and I'm the natural
spender at our house I'm in charge of
fun and uh she's in charge of killing it
no I'm kidding but they yeah
careful so careful now this could get
back to her she might actually listen to
the show one day
um so yeah no you're not being a stick
in the mud you are being yourself and
she's being herself and there's really
not a wrong answer here here's what I'm
thinking when I heard your whole story
this purchase of this van is upgrade
this van she spends a lot of time with
six kids while you're out there earning
all this income
and so this is a quality of life thing
for her this is not a frivolous
expenditure in her mind
the other thing I'm thinking is that
this is not a pattern that this lady
consistently wants to buy crap and you
guys don't make advances on your wealth
building plan that's not really who she
is this is a fairly rare request for her
I know that because your numbers tell me
that because you don't have a bunch of
other myths that she has made
so she's not a an overspender she's not
like a congressman you know I mean right
yeah it's this this is this is the the
biggest
biggest one with with multiple zeros
she's reasonably reasonably fruitful for
a Spender
yes yeah there's no she's not immature
she's not a princess she's not always
wanting something new I know that
because your numbers the fact that
you're debt free was six kids making 200
000 you've got almost a million dollar
or better than a million dollar net
worth tells me that she's not okay
because she would have destroyed that
where she or the pattern there so this
is this is not a pattern
given the life situation
um I'm gonna go with her on this
and Craig let me can I challenge your
mindset Craig in a positive way okay I'm
not getting on you I want to just give
you a different thought process you're
winning yes you're winning financially
and this rental house is another giant
win on top of all of the winning you've
done to this point celebrate the win by
getting a really nice car that your wife
really wants and understand that you're
not losing in any way shape or form by
spending a reasonably on a really nice
Suburban for your wife and I just think
you have to shift your mindset here
you're still winning and you need to
celebrate this big win by being able to
bless your wife and your six kids I
think you reframed that I think you'll
sleep a little bit better but you've
been so intense and we're proud of you
and it's what got you to this point but
we've got to learn you know I don't work
out very much I know people can tell
that when they see me but I've got some
friends that work out like crazy Dave
and they tell me I gotta have a cheat
day I gotta have an off day if I'm going
going all the time and I think it's the
same thing in this gazelle intensity
yeah yeah
so um yeah you drive like no one else so
that later you can drive like that's
right live like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else these are no discipline seems
Pleasant at the time but it yields a
harvest of righteousness and that's
where you are you have yielded a harvest
and you've done a really really really
really really good job
a b this is not a pattern on her part
this is a singular situation uh and if
you hadn't done a good job or this was a
pattern I probably would have sided with
you like if you had a bunch of other
debt laying around or something and you
want to do this instead of paying off
some student loan debt or something I
mean nope nope nope get rid of the
student you know but that you guys have
done been so superb and um and this lady
I can just tell by the Numbers she is
not an unreasonable person
she's you you married you married up
well done yeah well done yep good stuff
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five the first time I
was blessed I'll name drop to get to
meet the great Zig Ziglar Sharon and I
had lunch with him and Gene at this
little Italian restaurant about halfway
through the lunch zigg says Dave
you know I don't really respect a man
that won't marry up
and I got to tell you I deeply respect
you
great this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us we're so
glad you're here if you're listening the
show and you're trying to piece together
what we teach on our own you can do that
it's called common sense you could have
done it before you came to us live on
less than you make chop up your stupid
credit cards nobody ever got rich on
credit cards except the credit card
companies so this is really not rocket
science and there's like I think we have
had they said the other day something
like 4 billion minutes
of YouTube viewed of the show now
it's bizarre it's like 1100 years worth
of YouTube has been now viewed on of
this show uh and me and you and
everything else you know and so the
YouTube channel is massive if you want
to wander through all that stuff and try
to figure out what we do you can do that
but that's not the most efficient way
the best way to do it is just take the
class you'll just be the the nine
lessons in just a few weeks and the
average person who takes Financial Peace
University is debt free in less than two
years everything but their house houses
paid off an average of seven years it's
a proven system 10 million people have
been through it now again you could do
it with a Total Money Makeover book for
ten dollars at Ramsey Solutions right
now but that's harder this is the
easiest way to get the whole thing going
and it's the most efficient way for your
dollar for bang for your buck so we're
pouring jet fuel on the whole thing
right now the Ramsey personalities Ken
Coleman included uh Dr John deloney
included Rachel and Jade's classes are
already going but they're leading
Financial Peace University classes
they're the coordinators of some of the
classes online if you want to be in a
personality coordinated FPU class you
can still do that for Ken or a deloni or
George camel Jade warshaw Rachel Cruz's
classes are closed uh they're like four
lessons in already uh you waited around
too long on those but you can get in on
these and don't don't have fomo go to
financial fpu.com or ramseysolutions.com
and click on FPU either one thank you
for joining us Mason is in Idaho hi
Mason welcome to the Ramsey Show
how's it going better than I deserve
what's up
good so I'm 16 years old and me and my
brother do landscaping he's the owner
that I'm his lawn care manager I'm gonna
bring in probably about 45 000 this year
and closer to a hundred next year wow
good my Lord to put that money as I'm
still living at home and don't have a
ton of expenses
pay off your parents house oh my god
wow what are you doing again
uh we we do lawn care and Landscaping uh
we do a lot of work we have a really
fancy golf course so we do a lot of
property down there so wow and you said
your brother's your boss and you're the
lawn care manager how old's your brother
19. 19.
man yep I don't want to hear anybody
gripe about young people I mean I don't
want to hear anybody you can't find
something to do to work out there oh my
gosh he's projecting 100 Grand next year
why not why not that's a good story way
to go young man Mason now you're amazing
congratulations so your questions what
to do with the money
yeah I just was like investment what I
mean I'm definitely we're definitely
gonna move out at some point so stay for
a house and all that but you're going to
you plan to go to college
no sir yeah I had a boy
or if they take the right stuff if they
need it
what are you gonna do with your life
Mason
uh definitely do this for the next
couple years become keep the manager
going definitely get up there we'll see
where this business goes it's definitely
ain't growing we have four trucks and
we're having to buy a truck about every
other month it seems like but
um and then I don't know I'm trying to
thinking about maybe going into crane
work uh we have some cool classes over
here for that so
okay so the reason I'm asking all that
is not to be facetious it's to say
um the first and best investment someone
in your age group can make 16 to 26 is
in uh knowledge
that may or may not be a four-year
degree that may or may not be a a formal
series of classes but knowledge and the
thing you do need to do is be a
continual learner the rest of your life
so you're always going to conferences
reading books taking the occasional
class or whatever and uh and or in your
case maybe you are pursuing a certain
certification in crane operation or
whatever that is but I that's the best
use of this money because it's going to
give you the best rate of return
knowledge has the best rate of return of
any possible investment knowledge that
actually has utilitarian use in the
marketplace okay
that makes sense so yeah getting to
getting tooled up
you're getting your brain to in your
hands tooled up
to go do the next thing is always the
best Money Maker so that's what I want
you to do with money first so secondly
yeah you can begin investing and if
you're if you don't need to set us out a
bunch of money for a four year because
you're not going that route then then
you can start to think about Roth IRAs
file a tax return do a Roth IRA get with
a smart investor Pro they'll help you do
that and you can get a real head start
on that uh but if you told me you were
going to four year and you needed this
money for that I'd be okay with you just
setting it aside for that either any of
those are fine any of those directions
wow yeah really impressive and see this
is this is this is going to be an
entrepreneur
whether he takes the crane classes or
not I'm telling you this young man is
going to be creating jobs from a company
that he has started and this is the
entrepreneurial path and and I just
couldn't be any more excited to hear a
story like this and this is and I want
to be very clear and Dave's having fun
with me but I'm not anti-college I'm
anti-assuming that you have to go to
college to be successful and spend four
years time and money on a degree that
you don't even want and may not even be
able to use that's my position this
young man is an exhibit a of he doesn't
need the four-year degree what he does
need is as Dave pointed out beautifully
continuing knowledge continue to grow
and education is not exclusive to a
diploma at a fancy University education
is like Dave said reading books
listening to podcasts going to
conferences sitting with successful
business women and businessmen who are
winning in the field you want to be in
and so uh what a great story 19 and 16
year old brothers Dave yeah crushing it
had the exact same situation just the
other day I got some work being done on
one of our properties yeah and two of
these big trackhoes come up major major
cranes right grabbing rocks grabbing
stuff right talking to the guy running
it and um he's like 30 years old and he
owns the thing he goes I started
listening to you no he's 40 years old
I'm sorry he said I started listening to
you when uh 20 years ago wow I'm talk
radio and he goes I was I was running a
I was cutting grass I was running a lawn
care and I expanded into irrigation and
we expanded into tree removal and I
bought a couple pieces of heavy
equipment and he said now I own two
million dollars worth of heavy equipment
I run a heavy equipment operation wow
100 debt free the entire time absolutely
and uh high school graduate yeah and he
just kept working did good work
opportunities presented himself he
learned it acquired it did it expanded
it and I wonder how many people he
employs ah a bunch you see I mean you
got several million dollars worth of
equipment it doesn't sit idle that's
correct you know so he's creating jobs
yeah yeah this is how this is how
America Works boys and girls just a
little lesson for your economics class
that's true Karl Marx was not there this
is the Ramsay show open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our friend micro would be real proud I
was just getting that kind of thing uh
we were talking about this in the uh
America's labor crisis event we did a
few weeks ago that you were a part of
and we were talking and Mike and I were
talking about on stage that the he's not
he's about as hardcore Pro Tradesman as
anybody you'll ever meet that's right
and almost anti-college but not
completely in that college but you know
what we all agree on regardless of how
we're on that Spectrum you land is uh a
a useless college degree is useless and
too expensive that's right and so
getting a degree in German polka history
you're going to end up being a barista
okay this is just dumb all right and
you're gonna pay 250 000 for the
opportunity to draw somebody else's
coffee and so um nothing wrong with
being a barista but if that wasn't your
goal and that's where you end up by
default that's what I'm making fun of so
don't you Barista that don't let the
Barista Union start sending me hate mail
okay but the uh but he he our point was
that the currency all along has been
knowledge yes and somewhere the switch
got flipped and it the currency became a
college degree yes and it's not a
college degree the currency that moves
you into the next thing the thing you
spend to go into the next section of
your life is knowledge a college degree
can represent that but it is not the
currency that's right this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America this is the Ramsey Show Tracy is
with us in Orange County California hi
Tracy welcome to the Ramsey Show
thanks well you guys are not going to be
as proud of me as you were the first two
callers
okay try to bring it down oh wow there's
Tracy and then there's Tracy okay
okay so I've got a Bonus coming next
month about thirteen thousand dollars
way to go about 19. well here's where it
goes down I've I'm about nineteen
thousand dollars in credit card debt
with 17 cards open and I pay about 754 a
month on those cards now yes my husband
is not happy with me at all so yeah he's
the saver my question is do I pay off as
many of the lowest cards as possible
and 30 on the bigger ones I'm trying to
figure out what I should do with my
bonus money to get rid of as much of
this debt as possible
okay
um
let's answer that but let's kind of
circle around it for a second before we
date okay because because it does affect
uh the importance of the answer no I
won't change the answer but
um
are you done
yes
you're done you cut them all up I'm done
you hesitated they are they are all cut
up every one of them no well I had a
thing for a second but I'm looking at
them
my husband and I have had many heated
discussions about it and oh I don't want
to waste money about this has become a
this has become a thing okay it has
become a very
soon okay and uh are you two now gonna
move from uh him having serious
discussions at his wife's credit card
debt to now working together and
handling money together and never going
back here again
correct because as he says on paper we
do really well but I have a spending
problem so I don't want it to affect our
marriage as it is and I'm done well I I
I want you to be able to continue to
enjoy money as a as a vote on the budget
that you do together but that will also
ensure some accountability that you're
asking for and willing to do for not
over spending but I still want you to be
able to spend we don't want to go all
the way to his side and you have no oil
at all on the joints and start to squeak
you know what I'm saying yeah so
enjoyment of money is part of the
process as well it's not uh but but
overdoing it obviously is not the
process so having said all that that's
important because
um if you're not doing the things that
we've been talking about for the last
few moments no answer to your 13 000 is
going to work because this crap is going
to grow back
exactly okay so that's why I wanted to
set the table there for that so having
said all of that then let's just list
them smallest to largest regardless of
the interest rate balance smallest
largest balance and pay off as many as
13 will do you said there's 17 cards
I'll bet you that gets rid of uh 14 of
them
well I've got eight that are under one
thousand dollars and I've got nine that
are over one thousand dollar balance
okay so we know we got eight of them
that's 8 000 and then there's another
five thousand so I'm gonna be pretty
close
might be 13 instead of 14 but depending
on how those balances land but the good
news is and I tell you I I have sat with
people Tracy in the past like years ago
when I first started doing this and I
was amazed at what it does to your
emotions like when we would make a list
of all of their debts smallest to
largest and then we would look over and
say Hey you have eleven thousand dollars
in a savings account and they would have
these people maybe in the in those
situations have a little 75 dollar
medical bill from diagnostic because if
you drive near a hospital they send you
a 75 diagnostic bill that you don't even
have to go in you just drive past they
send you a bill it's like automatic it's
like a camera on the car and so you know
you get all these little mosquito bills
I call them little tiny ones and we make
a bit there'll be a list of 30 or 40
things when people first start this that
have been just hanging around because
they were disorganized and chaotic and
we would take ten thousand dollars and
wipe out like three quarters of the list
and it feels like you did more than you
actually did did mathematically you see
what I'm saying yes and when you knock
out uh 13 14 of these things you're
gonna you're gonna get that sense of
emotional momentum yeah and Tracy I'm
going to challenge you I mean first of
all every penny so let me show you you
hear us every penny of the 13 so that's
going to leave you with six thousand
dollars left and I would keep the
momentum going because I think you're
going to get a real uh shot of dopamine
when you strike a check and you cut it
down to six grand but I mean I would be
doing selling things I would be looking
for extra opportunity to make some money
and and put it on paper just as you list
out all of them knock out the rest of it
real fast how quickly can I knock out
the six thousand and if I think if you
do that before we cut the check for 13
so it all happens one two punch I think
you're gonna be surprised how quick you
knock out the six it's going to change
your marriage it's going to change all
this emotion that's been around these
heated conversations yeah
congratulations yeah and we're thankful
to have you in the listening audience
and proud of you as you say Dave she's
sick and tired of being sick tired yeah
that's when when you finally say I've
had it yeah that's when you're ready to
change until you're ready until you had
your I've had it moment and she has yeah
you can tell and no one can have it for
you isn't that the truth your husband
can't have it for you that's right you
know it's true you know I now value my
marriage and the quality of my marriage
not just my marriage but the quality of
my marriage above
the the spinning pattern yep I've had it
yeah and and that's a that's a that's an
adult decision right there it's not a
baby so she said we weren't going to be
as proud over as the other two I'm proud
of her yeah yeah I agree you're doing
really good I absolutely agree because
you know in some ways the the the
Constitution that it takes emotionally
mentally you're gonna have to really go
after this change the way you live and
think uh that's to be admired Tracy yep
it's to be admired that's uh change
isn't easy transformation is one of the
hardest things humans do oh yeah yeah so
you know it's interesting you're talking
about this idea that
um go ahead and lay out the plan for the
other six thousand that's very so
there's two things here yeah you guys
need to listen in here very clearly if
you're fighting debt number one when you
pay off smallest to largest you get a
positive feedback loop okay this is
telling you you're winning you're
winning you're winning you're winning
you're winning there's a light at the
end of the tunnel that's not an oncoming
train and so you will keep with
something that gives you a positive
feedback loop that's a psychological
phrase go look it up okay so if you if
you're getting if you're getting some
wins if you go on a diet and you lose
weight you'll keep doing it if you're
going on a diet and you gain two pounds
you quit negative feedback loop positive
feedback loop okay so you need things
there the second thing that happens is
and we do it here on the air with people
and they don't even realize we're doing
it to them is that when you lay out the
math for the first time
and you go huh
I really can do that in about four
months wow I never about Christmas were
that the math when you lay out a plan
even though you've absolutely done
nothing yet you just laid out a plan
that's all you did you just recognized
it as doable yes but you've actually
done nothing
your stress goes way down yeah because
your hope goes way up oh it's so true
and that's from a power of focus you
know when we know from psychology
research that when we focus on something
intently we begin to see it everywhere
the example that they've given research
studies is when you go buy a car last
time you bought a car live studio
audience you can play along with me here
you remember commenting on how you saw
that blue minivan or whatever you bought
everywhere over the next week even your
kids were like hey there's our car well
the god of cars didn't just drop them in
on the road it's that you focus so
intently on a purchase like this that we
begin to see it and as you described
when we begin to see that I can pay it
off in four months six months 10 months
here's what happens you begin to truly
see the opportunities to make more money
to cut expenses everywhere and it
becomes so believable and that's what
makes it so achievable because all of a
sudden you go wait a second this is this
is I can do this and the power of belief
is in stock yeah hope yeah it's hope I I
can see it it exactly was I I actually
have hope in an area I've never been
good at money I've always been behind on
my bills it's always been chaotic you
have all these negative self-talk things
all these negative messages and some of
you if you talked to my friend the way
you talk to yourself I would smack you
you don't talk to people a life like
that no don't talk to yourself that way
be nicer to yourself and let's get the
negative thing out of there and it's not
it's not a heebie-jeebie mysterious
stuff it's just like gosh I can actually
do this and
hope deferred hopelessness hope deferred
makes the heart sick but when desire
comes
yeah it is the Tree of Life
oh that'll preach this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
based on our ratings and our rankings in
the podcast and YouTube world and the
radio world there's a whole bunch of you
are new thank you we're glad you're here
and uh if you want to learn more about
what's going on what they're talking
about on the air and everything else hit
the uh get started button at
ramsesolutions.com it's a free process
that'll lead you kind of into where you
are and the different places we can take
you depending on what your needs wants
and desires are so check it out click
get started completely free no
obligation no salesman will call
ramseysolutions.com Josh is in Phoenix
hey Josh welcome to the Ramsay show
Hey sir how's it going better than I
deserve what's up
yeah I have a question for you so I want
to know would it be smart to sell my
current home to buy a smaller home to
have zero or little to no mortgage to be
able to pay off the rest of my debt
are you single
uh no you have children three kids three
kids okay
one's uh getting ready to graduate uh in
two days actually from high school
wonderful College what's your uh what's
your square footage
um I'm at 3 700 square feet right now
and what's the house worth
uh it's worth about a million okay and
what do you owe on it
uh 555. okay and what's your household
income
uh uh I'm retired so it's my pension and
my part-time job I would say about 12
000 take home
and how much do you have in a nest egg
uh I'm sorry how much money do you have
saved in a nest egg
about 20 000 saved
okay
your wife doesn't work outside the home
how do you pay a 555 thousand dollar
mortgage with twelve thousand dollars
uh my more so my mortgage
um is about three thousand a month um I
had another house that I had previously
owned and sold
um to put down on this house and I
bought it um when the interest rates are
pretty low
yeah but you make twelve thousand
dollars a year you said no no twelve
thousand dollars a month oh I
misunderstood yeah I feel so much better
for you I was so worried about you Josh
how's this guy living a million dollar
house with a poverty level income I
couldn't figure it out okay
life is better already okay do you have
any debts other than the house
yes I have a credit card debt about 41
000 and card debt about 53 000. and and
then I also have a HELOC that is about
fifty thousand okay and what's the big
car
um the big car is going to be
um about thirty thousand of the 53 okay
correct 30 of the 53. okay all right so
basically 150 Grand makes you debt free
and you make 144 000 or so a year
correct okay all right
uh do you hate your house
I actually love my house does your wife
hate your house
she loves it
um but I I just feel like there's three
rooms um in the house that we really
don't use and it's going to be four soon
once yeah I would sell fifty thousand
dollars worth of cars before I would
sell a million dollar house
okay and I probably would do neither
actually in your case but what I would
want to do is look up what you've
identified is that this 150 000 in
miscellaneous debts a problem that's
what you've identified and that the
house is overkill given that the kid one
kid is leaving
um but the house is wonderful you love
the house it's a great investment it's
doing well there's no problems with it
so in your case if I woke up in your
shoes is how we answer questions here I
would just double down on a budget and
talk to your wife and say if we keep
this house we got to stop overspending
and we gotta clean this stupid debt up
and that's going to involve rolling up
our sleeves and plowing through 150 000
worth of debt in about three years or
two years and or selling some cars and
doing it a little faster I don't care
which you choose to do but you guys have
just been sloppy
okay you make enough money to not be
this in our debt agreed right I I agree
yeah that's sloppy that's all it is a
credit card debt was just crap
you're just here or there picked up
something something popped up and you
didn't have any cash you only got twenty
thousand dollars saved and so basically
you just all the money comes in all the
money goes out and only the names are
changed to protect the innocent
correct yeah and that's not picking on
you it's just recognition of where you
are and where you've got to go if you
want to not be where you are right
correct and that's kind of where I'm at
now I just I want to get out of debt I
want to be debt free I had it once in my
life and yeah I want to get back there
again so I would like for you to be back
there and retain this house if you can
I think selling the house is a
desperation play and everybody's going
to be miserable because everybody likes
this house and I don't think it's
necessary to clean the mess up
mathematically but what is necessary is
you and your wife have a real talk about
this budget thing we're going to tighten
that puppy up yeah I agree and I I it's
interesting to see whether or not he's
driving uh this house situation or she
is it's not a bad move but I'm with you
I think they can get out of it and keep
that house and they're going to be in
they're going to be better off in the
long run when they're debt free and have
this house that's just growing you need
to change your habits anyway that's
correct you might as well change them
that's a good point let's see if you
can't clean the mess up yeah and keep
the house now even if you sell the house
you don't change your habits you got a
mess yeah now here's what here's what I
want to ask you because we have a lot of
new people coming in all the time from
all these different platforms
uh selling the cars is an option you
mentioned that but why in this case do
you say you know what you don't have to
sell the cars you can pay those cars off
uh I just curious why you take that
position I want people to hear that
basically it adds it's one third of the
debt okay so there's a forty fifty three
fifty so it's basically 50 Grand is each
each bucket that's right and he makes
150. right all right so what can we do
and we've got a 500 we got a 3 000
payment we got a 555 000 mortgage so
um you know it's not mandatory but it's
going to lengthen the get out of debt
plan by at least a year right right if
you keep the cars right and um they're
not quite high enough if one of them had
been 53 or 50 and the other one was
three right I would have probably sold
the 50. okay okay I'd probably pushed it
because I'm looking at Behavior patterns
right I'm trying to tweak there and get
that going but when they're both fairly
you know 30 and 23 that kind of thing
then there's no uh obvious offender
right there right it's more of a general
concept offender than this because it's
doable the point is they could pay those
cars off and then they got some because
I lean Dave I don't know if it's the way
I'm wired because I drove a lot of crap
cars for a long time I mean honestly and
and just because we were paying off debt
in Atlanta and I was driving older cars
and all that kind of stuff I just lean
towards if I can get rid of the car I'm
getting rid of the car because I don't
know if it's your teaching and being
your friend for so long but I go this is
a depreciating asset and a house is not
yeah I'm not trading the cars for a
house no no way never never always a bad
trade and uh and and all because here's
the thing think about this I was driving
through the neighborhood the other day I
was cutting across a thing and I cut
through this new neighborhood that was
in the Nashville area here so it was a
um
basically right in the middle class in
terms of uh price range it probably been
300 to 400 000 houses which is square
that's median household price actually
Nationwide that's a median home price
right now and so I'm driving down and
these nice homes that are fairly new
less than five years old are lined up
right down the street uh front opening
garage doors small lots and I'm driving
down through there and I'm seeing really
nice cars right in front of all of these
houses so they're they're sitting there
with fifty thousand sixty thousand
dollars yeah cars in front of a three
hundred thousand dollar house
a hundred percent of those got payments
on them absolutely and a hundred percent
of those people are trying to run a race
with ankle weights on right or trying to
swim with a concrete block life
preserver I mean whatever whatever bad
metaphor we want to use here right but
yeah yeah it's just and I'm going this
is the middle class it's exactly right
big depreciating cars and car payments
smaller home yeah wrong yeah you know
see and that's why Dave I've got this
and I I appreciate your advice and I
want our audience to hear this I if it's
me I'm a momentum guy I would I want to
sell my cars I would sell the cars I
would too because I I have bought this
whole cars my whole life I don't get
married to cars like some people do I
mean some people get a car and they like
it's so large selling it to some
emotionally because it's a big item yeah
sure it feels like selling a house but
you could do a car transaction six times
in a week you know exactly it's not a
thing yeah and so but house transactions
are super expensive so and you got to
move your butt every time you do that
anyway so uh but yeah I I I don't get as
attached to them and so I'm just like
I'll get another one yeah that's where I
land I bought a truck a couple years ago
and
had about five weeks on it I don't like
it I just went and got a different truck
I mean you know it's chain you know it's
not a big deal this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work because they love and
create actual amazing relationships open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author and host of the Ken Coleman Show
podcast SiriusXM 75 radio stations is my
co-host thanks for being with us America
Giovanni is going to start off this hour
in New York City hi Giovanni how are you
how you doing Dave I'm great good how
can we help
so my question is um pretty brief um I
work at a cell phone retail company and
I'm looking to increase my income on
studying to be a software engineer I
don't know if you guys were aware of the
Google keynote that came out not too
long ago regarding their new Ai and they
stated that their new AI knows over 200
plus different coding languages so in
your opinion should I still should it
still be worth it for me to study
software engineering or should I be
doing something else yes and the reason
is is even though that is true it is
their AI that can do that because of the
software Engineers they employ so I've
interviewed two AI experts and if you
want to get into software engineering AI
is not going to eliminate your abilities
to work in fact AI can only do what a
human programs it to do is it
intelligent yes but the reason they call
it AI artificial intelligence is because
a human software engineer software
developers are creating the code that
give the AI the ability to do what it's
going to do so you're going to be in
more demand than ever because AI is
coming like a freight train it's here
it's going to continue to expand but you
will be as valuable as ever so I would
not let that headline in any way deter
you let me let me give you a parallel
lots and lots of Industries have been
disrupted by technology AI is a
technology and it is going it is a major
disrupter it's going to cause all kinds
of things to happen it's pretty pretty
uh wonderful in one sense and scary in
another because the level of piracy the
level of counterfeits that are going to
come out of this or just if it's if some
boundaries of some kind even if they are
put on it you've always got the Russian
mafia or whatever hackers are going to
do what they're going to do right so you
you know this thing is it's it's a
powerful for good or for evil weapon
that has been Unleashed and it is there
so that's the reality now on a much
simpler plane about the time I came out
of high school when the dinosaurs were
roaming the Earth uh computers were
starting to kind of come on the scene
and uh three of my buddies were studying
to be architects
and computers suddenly were able to do
drafting uh with What's called the cad
system that is still in use today
although a much more sophisticated
version than 30 or 40 years ago but uh
the cad you know computer automated
drafting uh it's a lot easier to draw a
house plan or draw a building plan today
a lot faster than it was in the old days
when you had to draw it by hand now your
computer program can do it but you still
need people with draftsman skills and
you still need Architects to tell the
cad what to do and Engineers to tell the
cad what to do and so that's the
situation that we're the exact same
thing we're talking about here it did
not do away with the need for
Professionals in the industry it made
them much more efficient that's right
and people sitting if you wanted to sit
at a draftsman's board with a ruler
and uh whatever the tools were and draw
all day long oh you're out of business
you're done because no one does that
anymore because they it's no one it's
it's impossible to keep up with how fast
a computer can do that much faster than
a human but
um but to be able to tell the computer
what to do requires the exact same set
of skills yeah I want to give our
audience that may resonate with this
question here from Giovanni two pieces
of news so that you can get over the
fear factor number one we are seeing
right now there's about a job and a half
available a technology job just in
general tech jobs uh for every person
that wants to get in it so the
opportunity is massive in Tech number
two most of you have seen headlines
throughout the last six months about
major companies like meta Facebook's
parent company Google Lane tens and tens
of thousands of Technology workers off
and people go oh no but here's the deal
now the data has come back Dave that
those workers are getting hired within a
month for other smaller companies in
these big tech companies this is what
they do they staff up you had you had
companies like Redfin their CEOs Google
your Salesforce admitting that they over
hired to keep Talent away from their
competition and so the minute that the
recession word gets uttered these public
companies worry about their stock price
and they dropped talent but here's the
deal those people are getting rehired
quickly so all that to say if you want
to go into software I can't think of a
better field to get into right now yeah
it's uh
and you know creatives and content
producers yes of any kind audio video
that's right blogging all of that is
going to be affected yes but enhanced
here's the thing you have to in order to
be a thought leader you have to have a
thought isn't that true and and so you
know the AI cannot replace that and so
art Artistry you know quality graphic
production
um has to be installed by someone who
has the eye that's correct even if it is
then reproduced and replicated in its
various forms by AI so it's still there
and you still got to look at it and go I
think I'm going to use human judgment
here and say that sucks yeah I mean you
can still have that as a possibility my
guys typed in the other day that just to
make fun of me oh no in the in the chat
thing yeah the chat thing out Dave
Ramsey does a rant against AI
and it it formulated something I wrote
out a room yeah that's fascinating how
mad I was at Ai and it was pretty nasty
I mean it was um I mean not not nasty
like vulgar okay I was gonna say they
didn't add some color that you know
AI wouldn't have found me saying that
because I'm not father that's right okay
it has to find something you've actually
used to get the tone right oh yeah they
picked it up but it was uh pretty much
like me ranting against credit card debt
or student loan debt but just Ai and
they just oh that's an overlay and it
sounds fun obviously I didn't do that
but um because I'm not anti-ai and I'm
not freaked out about it uh the only
thing I'm actually worried about is just
that the stinking stuff steals
everything that and honestly a person in
piracy the piracy I mean the number of
copyrights and trademarks and images and
brands that we have developed at Great
expense uh ill you know a a nefarious
use well here's how to steal it well
here's what I'm concerned about is
people doing deep fake stuff yeah they
can put words in your mouth yeah and
literally create you saying something
you never said and I would just say as a
caution yeah please folks yeah that
we've joke about don't believe
everything you read or see on the
internet I think AI is going to make a
lot of crazy wacky stuff out there you
better consider your Source yeah that's
the kind of stuff like an effective
presidential election yes sir you know
they come out has yeah Biden's saying
something that made sense or something
oh
that's an interesting use of it maybe
they should try that
he strung a sentence together what
happened this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Ken uh lots of people
graduating from high school that time of
year and uh I gotta tell you I can't
think of anything we've ever done at
Ramsey that is as good as the get clear
assessment for a high school graduate
that you and the research team put
together this assessment is pretty
incredible and we've got it one
specifically built for teenagers right
yeah they get clear assessment that I
created a few years ago has been really
popular for adults and so I got with
Ramsay Ed and we said let's make a
student version is it possible for your
high school student to actually have
some pretty clear ideas about the
direction they want to go and the answer
is yes yeah career-wise but you got to
give them the tools to be able to dig in
and get some self-awareness and parents
here's why it's important very simply
it's going to help you help them make
that right education Choice what is that
right Next Step for them so that you're
spending that money you've been saving
wisely and they're time wisely and so
that's why we built this Dave it's the
student version of the get clear
assessment perfect time perfect
graduation gift for the student in your
life yeah the get clear assessment for
students is available right now it's
only 30 bucks uh get it for a student
absolutely the best 30 bucks they can
possibly spend know thyself right
ramsaysolutions.com store the get clear
assessment takes just a few minutes to
take it and the results the reported
spits out is Pretty stinking amazing
promise you it's worth a lot more than
30 bucks and so yeah you just don't want
to be the parent of the kid that goes on
to uh American Idol right and can't sing
yeah and you never had the guts to tell
them so Simon Cowell gets to trash on
national TV yeah that's exactly right I
mean like you know son you should not be
an artist all of your drawings are stick
figures that's right and then you know
you're really not up for this son the
flip side of this too is is uh over 50
percent of American college students
right now are spending five years or
more
and parents you don't want that either
and so help helping them get an idea
early discovering themselves right well
we actually have a tool that'll help
them see themselves and you can verify
at parents because when you see this
report you're going to be able to put
new language and new words around what
you've always known about your kiddo so
it's a fun tool telling the truth is
important it is Marie is whoops on it's
not Marie hello let me try again all
right Marie is there she's in Los
Angeles hi Marie welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi Dave hi Ken how are you great how can
we help
my question is is it wise for my husband
and I to put all the money we've saved
for our emergency fund and our down
payment
into a high-yield savings account and if
we move that much money at once is that
going to set off any red flags for the
IRS
answer number two is no it doesn't set
off anything for the IRS how much money
is in your emergency fund
how do you kind of
it either is or it isn't how much is in
your emergency fund oh you've got it
mixed together
right now oh no no no no no no no no no
no you need to separate these two into
two different accounts
because you will accidentally use up
your emergency fund for your down
payment when you get a house fever
no you separate them so let's declare
right now for purposes of our discussion
you can change it later an amount for
your emergency fund is 50 000. how much
then is in the down payment fund
240 240 000. so there's 290 total
yes good okay yeah these definitely need
to be in separate accounts high-yield
savings that you've looked up is paying
what
um somewhere around four somewhere in
the high 3.7 somewhere in the well
that's about three that's about right
okay and so
um
the 50 000 accounts gonna pay two
thousand dollars a year
okay or if you put in not a high yield
it's not going to pay half that right
but one thousand or two thousand does
not change your life on your emergency
fund it's okay to do it I'd like to get
a little more so yeah I'll move it to a
high yield that's fine but don't act
like you did something because it's not
enough money to worry about
okay the other account you're hopefully
not going to leave that alone long
you're getting ready to buy a house soon
aren't you
well we're kind of leaving that in God's
timing if it was my timing I would
have thought okay what is the sign for
you that God is ready
then would be basically starting his
career fresh because he's a when are we
going to do this if you think if God
showed up and told you it was okay
sorry what was the first chapter when
are you going to do this if it all falls
out similar to what you think it might
um I mean I'm ready this year
um
let me ask this Marie is it because he
hasn't found a job there's a lot of
trepidation and fear because he'd have
to basically start over is that what you
said
um
there's kind of a lot of different
factors but that that is one of them
what are the other factors it's really
important that's what we're digging at
what are the factors besides him getting
a good job what else
um
really it's it's just
um I mean you guys are our men of faith
and and you know that when when God puts
it on your heart that now is the time
then now is the time and we just haven't
felt like now is the time yet but
there's not any observable variables in
the marketplace or in your life that
you're waiting on that you're just
waiting on peace from the Holy Spirit of
Prayer
yes okay all right so I'm gonna give you
a guess and say in 12 months we're
probably doing this that's what I was
after how long are we tying up this 240
000 bucks are we going to tie it up for
five years or are we going to tie it up
for for six or eight months and it
sounds like six or eight months or a
year is probably right so yeah you're
gonna make a little money in a
high-yield savings account on this but
once again this is not a long-term play
this is a it's a quality parking space
for money that's all it is but we're not
we don't park money for long we're
parking it until we get ready to make
this move and uh that you know the Holy
Spirit releases you guys to go do with a
sense of Peace where you're where you're
going and so
um that's cool that's fine but I'm gonna
give you a reasonable guess and say that
these things are building up and there's
it's about ready to go this thing's
about ready to happen yeah I don't want
to take everybody to church here I would
just say to to Marie I I think her piece
would probably increase his peace would
increase if he had that job situation
cleared up and and I think that
sometimes we overthink and I think we we
we blame a lot of stuff on God I'm not
saying she's doing that but I am saying
that I think that at some point we have
free will and we have the option to make
things happen there's a there's a good
there's a good one-two punch here there
is it's the old uh uh Saint Augustine's
uh work like it all depends on you pray
like it all depends on God if you want
corn you've got to plan it and oh and
guess what you don't get control of the
rain or the sponsor right so that's his
part so you gotta do both there's a
one-two punch you do the do all of your
parts and sometimes the peace and the
timing lines up one of the ways I I
consider myself to be guided by God is
that the circumstances are lining up and
I have peace yes if the circumstances
are lined up and I don't have peace then
I wait if I have peace but the
circumstances aren't lined up then I
wait so uh and so I'm pushing on all of
those things at the same time because
there's this cause of effective works
and Faith that's right that are that are
a good part of a healthy mature
believer's process and it sounds like
you're doing all of those things I'm not
questioning we're not questioning that
but uh since we got all mystical there
for a second it's worth explaining how
we go at this stuff open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money
let's Circle back though and for the
rest of you on
emergency funds your emergency fund is
not
an investment
everybody say not an investment not an
investment it's not an investment it is
insurance
doesn't make you money it costs you
money
it costs you money to protect the things
that make you money
that's what insurance does the emergency
fund is not there to make money it's
there it's a pad an umbrella between you
and the storms of life
that's what it's for it keeps you from
cashing out your 401K which is making
money or having to put your home on the
market and fire sale it because you
can't pay the payments because you lost
your job it protects the assets that are
going up because it's a pad it's an
umbrella for the storms of life and so
what it makes is irrelevant because it's
never really gonna make much because
it's going to be liquid so if it makes
four or three point seven instead of 1.7
great but whoop-dee-doopty that's really
not what it's for go ahead and get a
little better parking spot but it's not
necessary to build wealth what's
necessary to build wealth is to have the
emergency fund separate this is the
Ramsay show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back Ed by their
watch and guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five today's
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
now that the weather is warming up it's
time to enjoy your outdoor space
neighborly's mosquito Joe service can
help make your outdoor area pissed free
so you can enjoy being outside in
Comfort visit neighborly.com to reach
your local mosquito Joe today
today's question comes from Jared in
South Carolina he writes my wife and I
are currently in baby step one and I'm
an associate marriage and family
therapist I work for a counseling job as
well as I run my own Counseling Practice
I don't have enough clients on my case
at this time and of course it's not
enough income I'm doing what I can to
increase the load to bring more in but
no success I specialize in couples
parenting Blended families and I would
love to do something with it such as
workshops but I don't know how to find
these opportunities any suggestions okay
first of all if you want to get into the
workshop space you don't find them you
got to create them and that that leads
to where I think you've got to go to
increase your pipeline this is just like
a sales job I mean you for your own
business you have got to create leads
that turn into opportunities so let's
look at those Target clients couples
parents Blended families so I'd start
with in your ZIP code your area who's
serving those people so you've got
churches have couples in them you've got
schools are are obviously taking care of
these parents children the Blended
families look and see who's serving
these are these non-profits are they
government agencies faith-based
organizations here's why if you make
yourself known to those organizations
that are serving your target clients
that you are a counselor and you offer
counseling services and you're going to
do a workshop online or in person will
they host a workshop if you take care of
everything else they simply open up a
room to you and make it open to their uh
their clients and so that's where you've
got to build the pipeline there are a
lot of people hurting right now and
you've just got to get in front of them
so I think that's the first thing now
the other advice I'd give Dave is this
while you're doing that to get momentum
baby step one which is for if you're new
listener new viewer baby step one is we
want to get a thousand dollars as that
starter emergency fund I'm doing
anything and everything Jared while I'm
taking the advice I gave you to make a
thousand dollars that's yard work that's
working a second a third job right now
just an hourly wage to get that first
baby step underway and that's going to
be a big victory for you absolutely
completely agree with that
um and and Ken is exactly right here
what we know post covid is that there is
a backlog a waiting list to see a
therapist to see counselor you can't get
in
so the fact that you have all this open
time is pretty
uh disturbing yeah so it means you've
done absolutely no marketing of
inequality so yeah I would contact
UM every business in the area that has
um 50 to 200 people working at it and
talk to the uh the whoever the HR
Director the the VP of operations and
tell them if you've got families in here
that are struggling we do marriage
counseling and if somebody's got
marriage troubles they're not really
working well right now they're
productivity's low so uh we'll help you
with that uh talk to the every Pastor in
a 20-mile radius just drop by and see
them say hey uh because a lot of them
uh have more counseling load than they
can handle that's correct and they and
you can get into sometimes deeper stuff
than they're one than they want to get
into uh and more extensive uh longer
term counseling situations than they
want to get into
um pastoral counseling is different than
being a therapist and so um or it should
be yeah so all of those things but yeah
you need to stir up some business is
what it amounts to uh if you let enough
people know that you're there in the
current environment that we're in you're
going to be overwhelmed with business
and that's where I would spend a lot of
my time so good question man we
appreciate you joining us Phil is with
us in Roanoke Virginia hi Phil how are
you
hey Dave I'm doing good um hey Ken uh
thanks for taking my call sure
um I just started listening to you guys
here a couple months ago um got my wife
starting to get into and stuff but um
I'm not sure what baby step I'm on
um I thought it was going good
um I thought it was uh paying down my uh
house early
um what I did about it a year and a half
ago I've had major problems with my
mortgage company so I went to my local
bank and uh they gave me the option of
either refinancing with the mortgage
payment or taking an unpickured personal
loan
so um I ended up opting for the
unsecured personal loan so that I had
the title in my hand with without a lien
on it and stuff like that and I've been
paying it down on Triple and payments
right now it should be paid off within a
couple of years but
um the more I listen to your show and
the more I look at your
web page and stuff like that personal
loans are considered Consumer loans and
should be baby stuff number two did I
transfer my mortgage loan from basically
a mortgage to a baby step number two
where I should deplete my
um
um safety fund and getting it off and
then build it back up or can I treat it
what's the balance what's the balance on
the loan
only like 22 000. oh how much is in your
savings account
um about 20 about 23 000. but that's
that includes my emergency fund I
understand fully funded emergency what's
your household income
uh 120 000. okay so let's pay it off by
September
yeah I I'm having little issues bringing
my wife on board with it we talked about
financial planning University we haven't
took forward steps on it yet she still
has a credit card I don't have any
credit cards so I'm slowly working on
her but it's gonna I don't know if I can
pick it by September where unless I get
her fully on board well that's another
issue
yeah yeah that's a lot bigger issue than
whether to pay the mortgage off or which
baby step you're on you're not really on
a baby step until the two of you get on
the same page and then you can talk
about baby steps because there's all the
data says that until you're on the same
page your likelihood of Building Wealth
is very low
oh okay yeah there's just very few
people drag a spouse Kicking and
Screaming into rich
yeah she she's kind of on board she just
I know you're covering for her
yeah I am yeah so y'all got to get on
the same page too I mean that's the
that's the 100 pound gorilla or the 800
pound gorilla in the conversation so
um yeah you guys gotta you get that
fixed and then all of a sudden this
other is going to fix itself I don't
really care whether you call it it's
only twenty two thousand dollars man you
make 120 and you got 22 in the bank I
mean you know it's not it's not like
it's gonna you can mess this up as long
as you keep moving towards it but it
should not take you three years to clear
this
three months maybe but it shouldn't take
you three years to clear it once the two
of you are on the same page that's the
big deal there and so um
all right Dave I got to ask you because
you've been answering this question a
long time I think this is a perfect
setup again a lot of new people all the
time on the show here you got a husband
who gets it he's all in he's crushing it
his life's kind of there in his words
still has a credit card
how do you get that Vision to align well
I think we just start talking about okay
number one cause of divorce in North
America today money fights and money
problems number one disagreement in
marriages money fights and money
problems so if we can get rid of the
number one thing in our marriage that
causes negative situations
that's a big deal for any marriage it's
thing number one I mean if the number
one reason you die of bear attacks is
you wear red shirts then you would go
I'm done with red shirts right you know
I mean it's like you that'd be it so
um whatever whatever metaphor you want
to use so that's number one so honey you
know it's very important for the quality
of our relationship that we get rid of
the number one problem of relationships
and that's for us to be on the same page
so let's sit down
and dream
together about what we want our future
to look like and let's get in detail
let's make it in HD high definition
dreams not vague fuzzy ones in the
clouds because where there is no vision
the people perish so we're going to get
on the same page and as our friend Henry
Cloud says we're going to have a desired
future and and we're going to design the
future in such a way that we both had a
vote on it we both want to be there and
we're both willing to sacrifice to get
to that future
and then we say okay what has to be true
that's not true now to get to that
future okay it will be the stop of the
use of the credit cards they'll be
clearing off these debts it'd be less
living on a budget together where we
should have it every dollar has an
assignment or an agreement and then the
dollars are all pointed at the agreed
Target once we've got an agreed Target
that we both had a vote on and buy in on
that's called vision
and it'll solve the whole thing yep
that's so good
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jake is in Atlanta hi Jake welcome to
the Ramsey Show
sure what's up
uh so my wife and I are celebrating she
just got accepted into uh grad school
for her Doctorate of physical therapy
yesterday wow um however yeah we're
super excited however we are also not
sure how to go about paying for this we
are debt free
um we've been debt free for the past
three years
um and we do not want to take out
student loans but that's looking like
our only option not not entirely sure
how to get her through grad school on a
single income
what uh uh okay I know what a master's
in PT allows you to do pt what does a
PhD give you that the Masters doesn't
give you as far as career opportunities
you run her own practice and prescribe
uh medicine and you know stuff like that
I think she can run her own practice
otherwise but she probably can't
prescribe medicine
without a supervising position yeah I
don't think there's anything that keeps
you from running a practice but the
actual prescription yeah no doubt about
that okay how much is it going to cost
this particular School
uh I think the estimated cost is about a
hundred thousand it's a two-year
accelerated program okay
and she's been trying to get into this
one or she been applying to multiple and
this is the one that said yes
that's right she's applied to multiple
and this is the only one that said yes
okay
uh Dave I I
my advice on this is I'd be patient
until I until I save the money up and I
would be looking to get into uh other
programs if this is even a reality I'll
be honest with you I don't know the
going rate I don't know what's what a
what a uh uh a low medium high prices on
physical therapy doctorates but nobody
cares no one not one patient will ever
care where she gets her doctor that's
the first thing I'd say oh well they
care if she hasn't even if she has it if
you want to run the practice
because if I go to a PT and I have I
have never once asked whether they had a
doctorate or whether that matter nobody
does they're a PT that's what they do
yeah so I'd be patient I would be
patient save up the money and I sure
would like to find a place where I could
go for 60. again if that's realistic
because nobody cares yeah I so there's
two categories that we pursue something
like this two buckets that cause us to
pursue something like this Jake and
we're leaning heavily on one of them in
this discussion bucket number one when
you pursue a degree or an advanced
degree of some kind like this we're
looking for what does that open up for
you as extra income potential or
opportunities in the marketplace that
you wouldn't have without it okay in
other words it's permission to play at a
different level okay and uh the point
we're making here is other than the
writing of prescriptions unless I don't
know what I'm talking about and I
probably don't actually but other than
the writing of prescriptions I've been a
patient to a PT but I'm not been in a PT
program and I've worked with a lot of
pts paying off their student loans over
the years and so um so I'm not sure this
adds a hundred thousand dollars in
Marketplace value to her career
that's my point in that bucket the other
bucket that is also a valid bucket is
the pursuit of knowledge
and the uh
academic pride of getting a PhD and that
is a valid thing to want to go get that
okay
you follow me so none of the none of the
and none of these discussions are we
trying to be a dream killer but um
uh you guys need to sit down and talk
about since you don't have the money to
do this
it needs to have Marketplace value more
than academic Pride value academic Pride
value would be called a luxury
to go get a PhD in something that
doesn't change my life okay
um that so whatever portion of this that
falls into that is the luxury portion
the other portion is yeah there's
legitimate opportunities I can expand my
practice I can do things I can't do and
I can make more money because I have
this and those are the two things you
need to look at and compare and talk
through and then we've got to figure out
a way to pay cash for it or I'm not
doing it
but what happens and it happens in the
medical field
more often probably than it does in
other fields is there is this Pride
there is a Prestige that goes with
uh I'm an MD I'm not a nurse
and they're taught that in the medical
school right I mean so there's a pride
uh it's a pecking order thing right that
goes with it and the PHD versus the
lowly Master's degreed
um but it other than bragging rights it
needs to have some economic value it
does and Jake if you've not seen our
amazing documentary bar future I really
would like for you and your wife to
watch it and if nothing else to
specifically watch the testimony of the
dentist and that and and that that will
just he went in over a million dollars
we're talking about a hundred thousand
here but it is not worth it and I think
Dave laid this out beautifully Jake this
is a need versus a want if it is an
absolute need then it is worth the wait
if it is a want
and it has no redeeming value Beyond
just the prestige piece and it's
absolutely you must wait is there a
Health Organization
that desires to have a PhD
PT working on their team that would pay
for this now that's a great point and I
think that's right because we're in it
we're in an environment right now if the
job Market's right in a certain part of
the country they go you know what I
moved my license over there and work for
you guys and you pay for my PhD yeah I
like that I like that approach I would
do that one uh in a heartbeat for either
bucket yeah just because you want a PhD
that's fine somebody else is paying for
it yeah yeah that's right yeah but um so
so guys um what has happened with the
student loan
debacle
1.7 trillion dollars 44 million
Americans
uh having their lives altered
and higher education's expense rate
going through the roof
and this false worship at the altar of a
degree now again I'm not aiming at
Jake's wife on this that's right just
making a general statement as a
follow-up uh but but this instead of
saying current knowledge is the currency
now degrees of the currency and then we
got over into the land of any old degree
and pay any amount to get any old degree
now we really got into a stupid Zone and
what the it what it started out being
was to expand your mind and your view of
the world yes so you would read English
literature
which does not have Marketplace value
does not does not change your income if
you've read English literature but it
does change your brain's ability to work
it does change your critical thinking
skills uh your vocabulary does that it
opens doors for you all of those kinds
of things method of speaking all of
these kinds that's an educated person
that that is there's a reality to those
things but we got so far over there that
now there's a bunch of us oh rednecks
that are going look it's got to pay for
itself
or we're not doing it
so you got to get a degree that's
actually usable and that you see a
measured change in your income that is
obvious that that is a reasonable change
in your income versus what you paid for
it an Roi that's right because here's
the reality and you'll see it in this
documentary bar future here's a dentist
that I absolutely believe when he got
into it he was passionate about the work
he knew what he could do but the weight
of the debt was so bone crushing that
you don't even enjoy you'll end up
resenting the degree and the work you do
because of the absolute whole that you
are crawl as you've crawled into and it
feels impossible to get out now we can
help you get out and we help that
dentist and we've helped a lot of people
but the point is there's no need to rush
into this one hundred thousand dollar
PhD don't rush save up get a grant uh do
what Dave said you know maybe you get a
company to fund it for you because they
want your talent there's a lot of ways
to do this yeah I just want you to think
about why we're doing it what we're
getting for what we're paying
you know everything else you do a value
judgment on accept education and on
education it's like anything we'll pay
anything that's right because it's
important I know it's not not at some
point this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Ken
Coleman Ramsey personality host of the
Ken Coleman show and author of the
number one best-selling book from
paycheck to purpose all about careers
and work as my co-host today the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five Scott is going to
start off this hour from St Louis hi
Scott how are you
I'm better than I deserve how are you
better than I deserve what's up
well uh I've been uh I work at a
mid-sized Church in
[Music]
Missouri there are two full-time people
for
about three and a half months and uh you
know I'm
I just need some advice on what to do
for my career and
um what my next steps are do you want to
stay there and keep growing within that
organization
maps of the area our community our life
groups
um
what do you mean when you're saying
you're doing the work of two people yeah
what's that mean so I work in Church
media and
our previous meeting a guy who left uh
about three and a half months ago so
I've been doing everything from Sunday
production video editing graphic design
volunteer management social media so I'm
just doing
everything and I'm uh I had about
whenever you left I said okay I can buy
this for about three months and
three months of fit I haven't heard
anything about my job and so that's so
I'm not sure so Scott that's why I asked
you the question because if you weren't
doing the job of two people right now
would you be calling us right now about
your career and your future or is this
I'm exhausted and I'm trying to figure
out if I stay or I go that's what I'm
trying to get to the heart of would you
be calling us if you weren't doing the
work of two people
I might have because I was uh
you know just uh my passion is video
editing and related kind of things and I
was
um more set as a social media sort of
role okay so so let me interrupt real
quick because that's important
distinction right there and I want to
validate what you're feeling because
this is not you're not I don't think
you're being sensitive here it's if
you're spending more time doing
something during your day that you
really don't enjoy that's gonna
eventually wear on you so in other words
I would say you're probably
um you're probably on the right bus but
you're in the wrong seat on the bus is
that a fair
diagnosis okay so when you ask an
opening a question I need some career
advice no we've got to really figure out
okay what's the tension you're dealing
with and you've got two tensions I hear
one is you're feeling a little
overworked and when someone feels
overworked it's very easy for them Dave
to start to feel underappreciated even
though that may not be the case I mean
there are times where where we are in a
great organization that we want to be
there and we're short-handed you know
what we got to pull the weight of two
people because we believe in the mission
so that's that's one option uh the other
option is when you feel overworked and
you're not hearing anything about hey
when am I getting some relief you start
to believe that maybe you're
underappreciated and we've got to deal
with that that's one tension the second
tension is are you in the right seat of
the bus and on the right seat I don't
think you are and so now the question is
is can't what must be true for me to get
into that right seat at this current
church do you understand and so you're
gonna have to talk with your leader
about both of those this is a this is a
adult conversation where we don't go in
with attitude dude we don't go in
feeling offended we go in with some
humility but we say to our leader I need
your leadership I need you to weigh in
on this we're about three months in I'm
feeling a little overworked here and and
I just want to get some direction from
you
um and then ultimately you know I want
to be in video editing and I'm spending
a lot of time over here what are your
thoughts on how I can get more into that
seat we've got to have that conversation
first because absent of that
conversation you're filling in the
blanks and that's not fair to your
leader and it's not fair to you
yeah does that feel like where we're at
I think so and you know that time when
you couldn't read your wife's mind
you remember that time
yeah yeah well your leader is the same
way yeah you can't read your mind they
don't know what's going on so you got to
go in and sit down and go hey
um listen I'm more than willing to carry
the water here and um I knew when
so-and-so left that somebody had to pick
it up and I was willing to do that I
can't do that long term because it's
going to break my back and so let's talk
about how we get some of the weight off
and let's talk about how I can serve
this place best in video editing and how
we can have a game plan to get there and
if I can see how we're going to get
there then I can help us carry the water
I'm I'm a team player okay and I'll do
whatever it takes I'm not a whiner but
uh but I can't this is not sustainable
and if your leader hears all that they
go oh yeah well I just thought you were
getting it all done I didn't I didn't
know you were working 80 hours a week I
thought you're working 40.
now they uh they know I'm doing a bunch
of overtime
okay yeah but again you gotta have the
conversation because this is when you
find out by the way Scott if it's a
healthy leadership culture
yeah Dave what's a healthy leadership
response to that if when a person comes
in with the right spirit and shares it
that way yeah I mean we don't want you
to work more than one full-time job and
we would prefer you to work in the in
your skill set and we would prefer to
work in your passion which usually are
similar and so yeah you've got you know
so if you want to move to video editing
hey I'm going to start we're gonna we're
gonna post and we're gonna try to get
the backfill on the other piece and uh
thanks for helping us until we can get
that backfill
and we'll get her done you know I mean
that's uh I can't but if you expect them
to wave a wand in 20 seconds suddenly
not you know this other position to be
filled you've got to work with them
that's right but if you're willing to do
that a healthy leader is going to come
alongside and go yeah
obviously we're a man down the guy quit
and uh you picked up a slack thank you
and so now we got to have a plan to
cover the backfill that's right and the
backfill may involve picking up your old
job and you take the other guy's whole
job that's exactly right it moves you
over to video editing if I understood
the story right that's right yeah good
stuff and I hear this a lot Dave and I
see it a lot on social media and I want
to caution some folks out there that are
feeling some frustration and I'm gonna
I'm gonna challenge you for a moment I
want to provoke you for just a second
it's not okay for you to be frustrated
at your leader if you have not properly
communicated with your leader
now I I rail on bad leadership all the
time because I see it and I hear from
people that are quitting jobs but I also
will be the first to say if you haven't
communicated to your leader very clearly
what's going on and and work with them
and give them a chance
with humility Insurance that's right
don't walk in there with a case of
Demands but if you haven't done that you
don't have the right to truly be
frustrated because as Davis that was a
great analogy it's like trying to have
your spouse assume that they can read
your mind or you can read their mind
it's just it's not healthy well when
you're dropping the pots and pans from
18 inches into the into the thing and
then I say what's wrong
you're supposed to have already told me
before you started dropping pots and
pans that's a very good I can't read
your freaking mind you know that's from
41 years of marriage thank you very much
yeah and leaders are the same way yeah
same deal
every wife uses that technique I think
at some point the door is just a little
it's something wrong nothing's wrong
black nothing's wrong black right you
know it's like yes something's wrong
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today Caroline is with us in South
Carolina hi Caroline how are you
how are you better than we deserve
what's up
so I just had a question about buying a
car while
we're we currently have a 19 year old
Honda Odyssey about 237 000 miles great
mechanical condition but it is a salvage
title because of hitting the deer
and our other car is a 16 year old Buick
it's only got 128 000 but we've had to
dump close to 2 000 and do it recently
so I kind of told my husband no more
than maybe another 500 if something
breaks down so I'm just trying to figure
out should we get another car and if so
which of the three options I'm
considering makes the most sense what's
uh what's your household income
um gross is about 90 but take homes only
about 65 to the mandatory retirement
what um
how much debt have you paid off so far
so that's a long story
um we just kind of stumbled back into it
accidentally
um I might be an education addict uh we
had actually paid off 60 000
um all of my Master's debt and then
I was working on my doctorate and I had
some cash flow issues and stupidly went
back in
okay
and that's the twenty thousand yeah
and I should graduate either the summer
or the fall with my doctorate good and
what
education I'm a teacher okay will that
change your pay
yes that will that between that and
South Carolina governments also
proposing so a pretty big pay raise so I
should be looking at probably a ten
thousand dollar bump in the fall nice
very nice okay all right here here
um
is what I heard
you tell me
and um I I I'm saying that because I you
get to choose whether I heard you
properly or not because you're the one
saying it
but I heard that every time something
comes up that you want to do
you jump back and forth in and out of
this
I want a car so I'm not gonna do baby
step two I want to go get my PhD so I'm
going to go back into debt and you're
never going to break the cycle
as long as you leave options on the
table
to violate the principles
um
what happened have any trouble except
education like we've never had any other
no no you just presented trouble to me
again you wanted to go buy a car while
you're paying off the debt from the last
time you fell off the wagon
yeah so this is two breaks in the past
about anything crazy no but this is two
breaks listen if you want to go get a
car you go get a car
I would not in your case it has nothing
to do with the cars and has nothing to
do with the financial situation you have
to break this pattern
that's what I think
I think you have a pattern of jumping in
and out depending on what feels good
right now and what you want to do and
I'm telling you you got to plow through
and have the transformation of the way
you view debt and the way you view money
and the way you you know you're not
scared enough about debt yet
you're not freaked out and mad enough
about debt yet
to where you're fighting it like it's
the enemy it's just a casual annoyance
that's what all of your language said as
you were discussing this yeah it's
absolutely right she's got options in we
take a no option stance
and so it starts to make sense when you
make it an option because then you look
at an old van you go oh we just put two
grand in this I don't want to put any
more money in this you know what there's
an option I can get a loan get a car and
that makes more sense I'd rather put
money into something that's newer that I
don't have to and it's just cycle if I'm
gonna quit eating Donuts I can't have
them in the house right it's not an
option probably not a good idea to drive
by the donut places yeah sometimes that
happens but I keep driving you know I
can't turn in yeah if I turn in it's
over yeah I can't you know if I have
them in the house a hundred percent
chance I'm eating them oh yeah a hundred
percent chance now when I was breaking
the cycle what I would do is get up
during covid on the weekends at six
o'clock in the morning I would go get
donuts because nobody was out right and
take them to my grandkids and I would do
that to make myself handle donuts and
not eat one wow and I did that to force
myself through the process but now I
know that I'm weaker now now than when I
was early and more enthusiastic in the
process yeah and I can't even have them
in the house yeah because I will eat
them I'm impressed that Papa Dave didn't
just at one point at a stoplight reach
over and grab one grab that that's
impressive
hot light is on Krispy Kreme and pop
that's my kryptonite I know I couldn't
do it that right there so you're telling
you all of us my point is I'm no
different Caroline that's correct we all
have this and so you have to have a no
take no prisoners approach to change a
behavior pattern so true to install a
new principle in your character that you
weren't doing before and you don't have
to take no prisoner's attitude about
this
and that's okay we can still be friends
but you're you're not going to execute
these things well and and with their own
us until you do so I would prescribe no
don't buy a car get mad pay off the debt
because the debt's standing between you
and getting a decent car because you're
driving a couple pieces of crap around
your house and I'd be sick and tired of
being sick and tired of driving crap and
this twenty thousand dollars is in my
way and I gotta get rid of that so I can
get an emergency fund and save up money
for a little better car and I'm gonna go
do that in a very short period of time
and I'm gonna be really angry about it
in a good way yeah I like that by the
way I don't want people to miss what
Dave just said there he it's simple in
what he said but it's pretty profound in
that you change the narrative to I'm
kind of I got a PhD I'm getting a nice
job I'm tired of driving around a piece
of crap so I'm going to save up change
my lifestyle and buy a nice car cash
it's a completely different shift on the
focus and the mindset it actually works
yeah well you got it you just gotta say
I'm I'm done with this I'm not going to
play games I'm gonna play you take the
option off the table I don't go in Banks
I don't go in the donut shop and I don't
go into a bank the only thing banks are
for is making deposits taller four tell
you what all this talk of donuts I might
stop by the shop on the way home tonight
yeah well just you don't have to shut up
come on Dave talk me out send me a
picture and tell me about it yeah
I thought Dave was going to Cuff me
there folks he's not helping me here
he's unhelping me but no it's really
true it it's taking the option off the
table you know I know you and I feel the
same way about marriage and I don't want
anybody to feel guilt or anything but
you know committing to one person you
have to take the option off of the table
we're not going to quit yeah murder's an
option but divorce is not that went a
little dark I didn't see that coming but
one of my pastor friends says you will
never hear that he cheated on his wife
you all hear he died tragically in the
home right
that's good
oh man it was a tragedy it was a tragedy
tragic well there's an extreme thing
because there is a principle in the
principle of transformation the
principle of behavior modification that
you have to and it is smart too
swing the pendulum way over into crazy
to completely break the cycle in your
brain right and then when he comes back
a little bit it doesn't come all never
wanted to come all the way back because
you're in crazy over on the other side
but when it comes back a little bit
you're relaxed a little bit my budget
has a lot more margin in it than when I
very first started doing a budget and I
was a broke person it was to the penny
yeah and now it's like yeah what a you
know but I'm still got a budget still
got a plan right and I used to have
groceries separated from restaurants
because I couldn't right I would we'd go
out to eat and use up the grocery money
and but so I had to have more I had to
swing it more detail more intentionality
more intensity yes but now 30 years of
doing this I mean we've got margin in
the budget number one number two you
know it doesn't matter but you and
Sharon and all the people that have done
this so you said you break your appetite
for debt yeah I mean years ago I almost
break my appetite for living without a
plan I'll always have a plan exactly but
it's it's a I got rid of sweet tea years
ago I can't even drink it anymore you
know why because for about seven years
you're not even a real Southerner I know
folks but now it's a Southern Man card I
know but you change your appetite
and that's huge you and but you got to
break it's okay with the donuts the tea
just got me I know well that's just my
only thing I like other sweet things but
not the sweet tea anymore it's too much
too much all right we really had sugar
and the tea was an excuse
yeah exactly this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
well the stock market's weird
that's a statement that'll stand up
almost any time
things are going bad things are going
good you can just say the stock market's
weird yeah there you go hey if you're
freaking out don't Market dips don't
mean you have to retire broke it just
means the Market's going up and down
roller coasters are no fun if they're
flat
and no one gets hurt on a roller coaster
except those that jump off in the middle
of the ride listen if you had invested a
hundred dollars a month from age 25 to
age 65 in the last 40 years you'd have
well over a million dollars in a good
growth stock mutual fund now I know some
of you are going that's a great plan
Dave if I was 25 but uh you can start
where you are that's the place to start
and a huge predictor of investing
success is that you actually invest
oh that changes the numbers
substantially all this theoretical
discussion is a bunch of crap so get a
pro in your corner go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on
smartvestor
ramseysolutions.com smart investor and
you will find what we call a smartvester
pro
which is the group of Pros thousands of
them Across the Nation that we have
vetted and that have the heart of a
teacher and that help you with
Investments the same way we talk about
here on the air so when we talk about
spreading across four types of Mutual
Funds growth growth and income
aggressive growth and International
they're going to help you do that do we
talk about buying mutual funds with a
long track record not something that's
been open two years they're going to
help you do that and they're going to
show you and teach you and teach you and
teach you and teach you to where you
will say I invested
using a Smart Vista Pro not I got a
smartvestor pro to do my investing
you should never do that you should
always do your investing
with the help of a teacher
that is you being a grown-up and taking
responsibility for your future so
ramseysolutions.com
smartvester and get somebody in your
corner to help you do your investing
Davina is with us in Houston Texas hi
Davina welcome to the Ramsey Show
all right I can't believe I'm talking to
you you Hi how are you better than we
deserve how can we help you
um so I'm a nurse I only have a 401k in
my job so I'm wondering if I should
switch careers and be like a flight
attendant or something or go work
somewhere where I know they offer a
pension if I stay for like x amount of
years I don't really know what to do no
you probably should not do that because
it sounds like the only reason you're
considering a career change is because
of the so-called pension that you think
is more valuable than your 401k is that
fair
yeah you like what you do now as a nurse
you enjoy it yes yeah yeah okay yeah no
you should not do it
okay you you have you have just as much
investing power yourself
and the pension is not all it's cracked
up to be it sounds like one of your
patients was smoking dope and told you
to do this
exactly
I'm like or sorry
um like what do I do in my life so all
of a sudden this guy talks you into this
oh pension thing he was sick Davina I
remember that okay
was he on pain meds at any time in the
conversation oh yeah no no listen listen
why shouldn't she do you today listen
never
take a career yeah choice because of
benefits
money will always buy benefits go make
money
put it in your 401k put it in your Roth
IRA
beef up your insurance if you need to
because they don't have great benefits
at your place but I have never made
financial decisions as far as my career
goes based on benefits and I've always
made enough money to provide myself any
benefits that I would have needed
including retirement including the
ability to retire with dignity and so
forth choose a career based on something
you're gifted at that you love that you
can pour yourself into and that you can
make a really good living doing it and
the benefits will take care of
themselves either you will take care of
them or they will show up at the place
you work one of the two but don't go get
I got whiplash I'm a nurse and then I'm
a flight attendant or something it was
just like I've got to go where the
pension is no and I I Dave I that's old
school pensions aren't all they're
correct up to they're not good at all
why do people think they're so great
well they're almost all gone right
that's the other thing just about out of
the business and many times poorly
managed I doubt if you were a brand new
flight attendant entry level today if
you're going to qualify for a pension
they probably have done away with them
yeah there may be one airline that still
has that or something I don't know but
that's just not a plan not a plan nope
nope nope nope nope go make money yeah
and that will cause you to have the
money to buy your stuff all right Jacob
is in Greenville South Carolina hi Jacob
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
yes sir I was wondering how much should
me and my wife deplete our savings to
pay off our debt with a one-year-old son
at home
uh down to one thousand dollars
not counting your retirement don't touch
retirement
yeah so we don't have any I don't have
the shoes she has one 401K I don't have
a retirement okay I'll stop stop adding
to the 401K temporarily and I would get
on a detailed written budget and I'm
going to attack the debts smallest to
largest paying minimum payments on
everything but the little one and attack
the little one with a Vengeance we call
that the debt snowball when the little
one's gone you take all the money you
can squeeze out of your life in your
budget and you throw it out to that you
don't eat out you don't go on vacation
you're not going to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
so this we're going crazy we're
completely focused I'm going to knock
out this debt really really fast because
with only a thousand dollars in the
account I am really nervous that is not
a good long-term plan but it's a great
short-term plan to get the freaking mess
cleaned up how much debt have you got
I have a 19 about 19 000. okay on what
um I have a uh nine thousand dollar uh
truck payment uh my eight thousand
dollar we got our windows replaced
um just recently that's uh for our
Windows replacement
um 1200 and uh medical and 1400 in
student loans gotcha and what's your
household income
uh I bring home pay between both of us
is 62 000. all right and how much is in
savings
21 000. okay all right we can just about
clear up all your debt
yes sir that was my question I just
found you two weeks ago um and I'm sorry
I just bought your book and I'm all in
so is she that was my question
yeah yes sir she's coming around okay
yes sir she's uh she's nervous about
hitting or getting our savings hit so
you don't let another salesman in your
house that sells stuff like windows
again
unless you're gonna pay cash for it okay
because that's what happened that's what
happened somebody came in and sold your
windows and and obviously you're gonna
pay cash for any vehicles from this
point forward your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income and what we
did was we got rid of a truck payment a
window payment and a couple of other
little things that were just bothering
you and now we got your entire budget
cleaned up and now very very quickly
with no payments at all we're going to
take that one thousand dollars and build
it back up to 20. yes okay okay Jacob
have you written down or do you know off
the top of your head all of those
payments right now from those debts you
listed out what does that add up to each
month in your budget
payment
um the whole time is 280 we've been
paying 300 a month okay 300 on the truck
how much is a window payment
um minimum is uh 350 we've been paying
for 100 that is interest free but that
doesn't matter and uh you said the other
was a medical you pay anything on it
yes sir we're paying the the minimum
amount at uh 321 a month wow okay 300.
okay and the fourteen hundred dollar
what's the payment on it
there's eleven hundred bucks a month
yes sir okay so you got 1100 bucks a
month plus whatever else you can squeeze
out of your budget and so in about 18
months or less you're gonna have your 20
000 built back up probably about a year
you're gonna have your 20 000 built back
up
and so you're only going to be at a
thousand dollars for one month yep
your wife needs to know that's this
month Hang on we're going to put you
guys through Financial Peace University
we appreciate you joining this tribe
you're brand new to it and we're going
to pay for you to go through the class
for free on us both of you go through
the class together and go become
Millionaires and then we'll brag on you
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day James 4 17 so
whoever knows the right thing to do and
fails to do it
for him it is sin Peter Marshall said
may we think of Freedom not as the right
to do as we please but as the
opportunity to do what is right
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Vincent is with us in
Houston Texas hi Vincent welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey Dave how you doing sir better than I
deserve what's up
uh yes uh basically my question is uh
should I
uh move and commute for basically a
promotion which turns out to be eighty
eighty thousand dollars approximately
forty dollars an hour
or stay with my current 18 an hour and
make approximately forty thousand so we
kind of doubles my income
but the thing is if I take the promotion
obviously I will have to move
in the cost of living uh uh it would be
almost triple when I'm paying out on my
mortgage
my mortgage I pay approximately 800 a
month of course plus utilities which
is not much
um in the new place it will be
uh around maybe 22 to 2500 a month plus
what are you talking about moving to
Vincent
um Dallas Texas
where Dallas Dallas
okay so the cost of living in Dallas is
not triple the cost of living in Houston
your your housing situation may go up
but the cost of living is very similar
in the two cities
all the other causes of living issues so
your current residents you own it right
what is your mortgage balance on your
current residence
uh a little under sixty thousand
okay and what is it worth
um it should be around 260. okay so you
have a two hundred thousand dollar
Equity that you would take to Dallas to
buy something with
and that doesn't necessarily put you in
a twenty four hundred dollar payment
oh that's not accurate
yeah well I mean I was just thinking
because uh this is kind of like um
you know moving maybe for a few years
because I mean I have my parents and
everybody here you know my wife family
and you know so I'm I've been commuting
and I've been paying so what is the new
job
the new job I'm a aviation maintenance
technician
okay and there's no aviation maintenance
technicians that make 80 grand in
Houston of course there is
ah there
or they are but I mean I I'm already
I've been with the company for a few
years and I just got the promotion you
know uh you got a promotion that moved
you to Dallas
yeah that's kind of what I'm I keep
thinking like that doesn't make sense
you know to you know the way I'm looking
at it is if I move it's literally taking
me
yeah let me tell you what I keep hearing
okay you keep giving me 73 reasons why
you don't want to move to Dallas
I don't okay and are you commuting yeah
he's commuting to Dallas that's crazy
yeah yeah you can't keep it up so I
think you look for an airline
technician's job making 80
but I don't know why you need to make 18
an hour to stay in Houston that you
don't if you're doing Airline
technicians work in Dallas for 80 grand
there's Airline technicians work for
somewhere around 80 grand to do in
Houston I promise you there's as much
aircraft in Houston as there is in
Dallas
you'd have to change companies but
whoopty Dumpty this company ain't
working for you
yeah
so you get to decide which pain you want
do you want the pain of changing
companies or changing cities
no I I really don't want to leave my
parents I mean they're they're getting
something they change you just decide
what pain you want to
so it's time for you to say I'm going to
straighten my backbone and throw my
shoulders back and change companies or
I'm going to walk in talk to my boss
about making 80 grand in Houston because
my days of talking about moving to
Dallas are over because I'm not moving
to Dallas yep Vincent how long you been
with this current company
um
is I mean
three years
with the new position it's been a little
over like a year here's the deal it's a
scary thing for people to move and
you've got to identify what you're
scared of okay specifically and I'm
telling you once you identify what those
are there's there's no evidence of that
and Dave's exactly right you have skill
uh where you bring more to the table
than just even be able to work on air I
mean uh uh airplane engines so you've
got to open up your world to what your
skill and experience would allow you to
do to make the kind of money you want to
make so that you stay in Houston because
you know 16 people yeah that work
doing what you're doing at other
companies and when you pick up the phone
and call them you're gonna have a job in
a week
you're just a guy that doesn't want to
feel like you were disloyal to the other
company and you're not you and if you
want to give them the opportunity to
hire you in Houston for 80 grand that'd
be okay too to say guys I can't do the
commute and I'm not willing to move to
Dallas
and so
um you know let's let's is there
anything you can open up for me here
that makes us close to that where I can
do this job in Houston
and if not then start making some calls
to your buddies in the business you've
got guys right across the tarmac and you
know exactly who they are their faces
are popping into your mind as I'm
speaking and you know you're going to
call that guy and you're going to call
that guy and you're going to call that
guy and that gal and the lady that works
the front desk at the FBO and in you
know in three days dude you're gonna
have a job
so because aircraft is that way right
now it's it's hot
and uh White hot so yeah
it'd be like being in technology or
something yeah you're in a you are in
the driver's seat so uh I appreciate
your humility but uh I want you to take
on some more confidence and boldness on
how you approach this gently and kindly
with your existing company but Vincent
you don't want to move to Dallas
you told us that 73 different ways so no
you should not move to Dallas you should
get a new job in Houston making better
money yeah I agree because what will
happen is you'll begin to resent this
very opportunity because your heart's in
Houston and your body's in Dallas and
that's never going to work for anybody
it's not even fair by the way to your
current employer because you're half
there if that over time because your
heart's in Houston and it's where he
wants to be with his family so it's a
no-brainer but a lot of people Dave are
very scared of they just got a promotion
and it feels counterintuitive feels
almost stupid if I could use a a kind of
a bold word to go well I just got a
promotion and now I'm going to leave and
go somewhere else so that's because
you're too worried about what everyone
else is going to say but but in this
situation you know what's important to
you and you've got to make work
decisions that align with your values
yeah your family you know your your guy
that lives in Houston that's what you
told us you very very clearly and so
um so this is this this promotion for
you was not a blessing
other than it made you realize you're
more valuable than eighteen dollars
that's right uh so it did help you with
that part but it wasn't a blessing
because all it did was put you in a bind
and made you feel like I'm being pulled
by oh I should be smart and take the
money but I don't want to live in Dallas
and so that's the conversation you and I
had here for a few moments and you're
good you're a good man by the way I want
to add one other practical thing Dave
because I've I've counseled people on my
show on this one he's also wondering
what does it look like I just took this
job and three months later I'm looking
for a new job nobody wants to look like
a flake and that's a legitimate concern
okay because people look at your resume
but here's the narrative you've got to
sit and tell these new potential
employers you know what I took this job
because it was a great bump but I've
been working hard for this but here's
the deal my parents are older and I
realize that I need to be with them
right now people understand that that's
not a flake you're not going to look
flaky and flighty and look like a job
Hopper you're gonna look like a guy who
cares deeply about his parents and you
know that for this season I need to stay
close to home and and that's part of his
concern there it is that'll do it
good work guys well done well done that
puts the sour of the Ramsey Show in the
books
Ken Coleman good hour thank you sir well
done
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Rams and
baby steps go to ramsesolutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
again that's ramseysolutions.com and
click get started
[Music]